pages and pages of censored blacked out
reports of secret US and UK talks is
this the moment Russia successfully
interfered in British democracy no one's
doubting the authenticity of these
leaked trade files but the online
platform reddit where they apparently
first appeared has drawn a link with a
previous disinformation campaign
reportedly originating from Russia this
expert was the first to sound the alarm
the really big question is how did the
leaks get there in the first place what
was the train that led those leaks from
an internal UK collection out onto the
Internet
whether it was somebody handing over
documents whether it was a hack and a
leak we just don't know but those are
the kind of questions that really need
to be asked internally within the UK
government what's known is on October
the 21st an account called Grigory ATAR
posted the leaked documents on reddit on
November the 27th Jeremy Corbyn used the
files to attack the Tories by December
the second analysis emerged about the
possible similarities with an alleged
earlier Russia linked campaign called
secondary infection then on December the
6th reddit said it too believed there
was a link the site banned 61 accounts
there's little doubt that this was some
kind of information campaign which is
commonplace during election time this
Twitter account spent weeks trying to
attract the attention of politicians and
journalists to that original reddit post
even the Labour Party the key question
is whether or not a foreign state was
involved I approached the Russian
embassy to ask about the possibility of
Russian interference but a spokesman
said that didn't deserve a serious
comment labour - batted off the
controversy what are we concerned about
the veracity of the document or where it
came from and and and if a government
spokesman
a person wants to come up and say it's
not our document and so be it Hillary
Clinton might have something to say
about that logic her 2016 presidential
campaign was targeted in an alleged
Russian hack and leaked of emails the
Tories are concerned about the origins
of the trade leak but they face their
own controversy over the refusal to
publish a parliamentary report on Russia
the government obviously is taking steps
we are very aware of the potential for
overseas interference and watching very
carefully through or lots of different
channels as to what potentially might be
going on Britain's cybersecurity center
is investigating the leaked files given
the importance of information at
election time the quicker they can
provide answers the better
Deborah Hanes Sky News